et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Sandrine Rousseau bonjour bonjour C'est
beaucoup d'être avec nous depuis
écologiste de Paris on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Fabrice dessert don du
groupe hébral et journaux de l'Est de la
France bonjour Fabrice bonjour Oriane
on va commencer en parlant de ce qui
s'est passé ce weekend à Sainte-Souline
Sandrine Rousseau une manifestation
interdite contre les mégabits a provoqué
de violences affrontements entre
certains manifestants et les forces de
l'ordre il y a eu plusieurs blessés
pronostic vital engagés pour l'un des
manifestants est-ce que vous condamnez
clairement ces violences y compris de la
part de ceux qui sont sont pris aux
forces de l'ordre
comme je l'ai déjà dit je condamne
toutes les violences mais là il y a une
responsabilité dans le maintien de
l'ordre dans cette manifestation et en
fait il y a une responsabilité du
pouvoir politique et ça n'est pas pareil
de donner des ordres de lancer jusqu'à
4000 grenades visiblement il y a eu 4000
grenades lancées et
la responsabilité des manifestants qui
étaient là pour défendre le bien commun
qui est l'eau ça n'est pas la même chose
et en fait ils étaient tous là pour
défendre bien commun ah oui ils étaient
tous là quand vous venez avec des haches
avec des boules de pétanque avec des
couteaux il y avait des il y avait des
individus violents c'est indéniable mais
ils étaient là pour défendre un bien
commun oui et là on a une une situation
où en fait on défend l'appropriation
d'un bien commun avec moult force de
l'ordre et des attitudes violentes de
ces forces de l'ordre alors que on est
dans une obligation de transformer
agricole on va parler évidemment au fond
du problème et de la question de
sébacine mais pour vous c'est uniquement
du côté des forces de l'autre qui a eu
des attitudes violentes non non je vous
ai dit qu'il y avait des individus
violents donc je vous le dis il y a des
individus violents maintenant ce qui
s'est passé du côté des forces de
l'ordre est inadmissible et inadmissible
vous dénoncez une débauche de moyens en
matière de sécurité mais c'est une des
moyens c'est une intimidation une
politique de l'intimidation et moi je me
demande dans quelle mesure il n'y a pas
de la part de Gérald Darmanin et
d'Emmanuel Macron la volonté de d'aller
chercher l'incident et d'ailleurs il est
en train d'avoir lieu puisqu'il y a un
homme aujourd'hui de 30 ans qui est
entre la vie et la mort de l'eau pour
avoir défendu de l'eau pour vous il y
avait une volonté délibérée de Gérald
Darmanin de projeter je trouve que
depuis quelques temps quelques semaines
il y a une modification de la politique
de maintien de l'ordre dans les
manifestations et qui est beaucoup plus
dur et violente qu'elle ne l'était et je
pense que oui
manifestations non je rappelle quand
même qu'il y a des pays qui ont modifié
leur politique de maintien de l'ordre
particulièrement en Angleterre et en
Allemagne où il y avait des hooligans
qui étaient ultra violents et
aujourd'hui en Angleterre comme en
Allemagne les manifestations se
déroulent bien donc en fait la volonté
de par exemple le retour de la brave m
qui est
qui avait été créé pendant les gilets
jaunes qui est une brigade qui
est une brigade d'intimidation enfin il
n'y a pas d'autres termes
de maintien de l'ordre c'est une brigade
d'intimidation la Bravet est une brigade
d'intimidation qu'elle revienne en force
est un signe manifeste qu'on veut tendre
les choses on va reparler de la brave
puisque il était pas question de la
braver ma sainte Soline aucune
intimidation qui fera taire les
mouvements sociaux tels qui sont
actuellement enfin vraiment on va
revenir mais juste il y avait des élus
écologistes des parlementaires
écologistes qui étaient présents à cette
manifestation qui était interdite il y a
le brun Pivet la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale hier c'est digéné
que des parlementaires en freinent la
loi qu'ils se mettent en contradiction
avec le mandat qui est le leurre c'est
ce qu'elle dit elle souhaite qu'il soit
sanctionné dans le cadre de la loi
n'a-t-elle pas raison mais il n'y a pas
d'interdiction à aller sur un aller sur
un terrain privé et à être là et
à être présent et au nom de quoi il y a
le Bruno Pivet nous dit où sont les
bonnes minutes et les mauvaises luttes
enfin pardon mais
dans des manifestations interdites c'est
ça
déjà été à des manifestations interdites
et j'y retournerai autant que de besoin
autant que de besoin et là en
l'occurrence c'est un une priorité
numéro un pour nous qui est comment
maintient-on un partage de l'eau alors
que l'eau se rarifie en France et que
nous en avons besoin c'est un bien vital
c'est un bien commun comment fait-on
pour le partage de l'eau et bien ces
rassemblements sont d'utilité publique
qu'il y ait des éléments violents à
l'intérieur de ces rassemblements
dommage mais c'est rassemblement dont
l'essentiel est pacifique quand même
parce que c'était des rassemblements
familiaux mais contre les méga bassines
que ces rassemblements aient lieu et
d'utilité publique justement sur
laquelle sur le fond du dossier puisque
cette Soline c'est la question des
bassines et des retenues d'eau pour
l'avenir d'agriculture c'est ce que
défendent ces promoteurs
est-ce que il y a quelques cultures sans
eau est possible quelle est
l'alternative non mais les gabacites
c'est typiquement ce qu'on appelle la
maladaptation au réchauffement
climatique c'est-à-dire qu'on fait comme
si on allait pouvoir conserver une
agriculture telle qu'elle est
actuellement comme si rien n'a changé
simplement en conservant en s'accapant
une partie de l'eau et ça n'est pas
possible pour nourrir la population pour
nourrir ça n'est pas possible de
continuer l'agriculture telle qu'elle
est actuellement il y a le rapport du
GIEC qui est sorti on doit diminuer de
moitié nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre il n'est plus du tout certain que
nous arrivions à rester en deçà de 2
degrés nous sommes dans une situation
d'urgence absolue et avec les
agriculteurs ne s'adaptent pas qui ne
font pas d'efforts pour s'adapter au
réchauffement il n'y a pas d'adaptation
à la hauteur des enjeux climatiques et
par ailleurs on ne peut plus continuer
les cultures de maïs comme on le fait ou
des cultures qui demandent énormément
d'eau je rappelle par ailleurs que des
méga bassines dans les Charentes
Maritimes il y en a 5 qui sont
interdites par la justice et qui
continuent à exister et que par ailleurs
c'est une région dans laquelle il y a un
énorme problème de retrait gonflement
des argiles ce qui fait s'effondrer les
maisons individuelles et que si les
nappes phréatiques ne sont pas
correctement alimentés alors ce problème
s'accroît comment peut-on mettre en
danger des populations entières
simplement pour s'accaparer de l'eau
pour continuer à faire du maïs cela n'a
pas de sens et c'est vraiment typique
d'un système productiviste qui est prêt
à recourir à la violence plutôt que de
vouloir s'adapter je dis nous sommes à
la limite de ce système là et nous
devons absolument regarder cette limite
parce que pour vous il y a vraiment
aucun effort les agriculteurs ils
s'adaptent pas au nom des agriculteurs
et particulièrement ne fait aucun effort
pour essayer de modifier les productions
non nous ne faisons pas d'efforts pour
diminuer la consommation de viande non
ne faisons pas d'efforts pour diminuer
les cultures de maïs nous faisons comme
si l'agriculture allait continuer comme
elle est aujourd'hui ça n'est pas vrai
ça n'est pas vrai et c'est mentir que de
le dire et c'est accaparé des ressources
précieuses que de vouloir continuer ce
modèle là ça n'est pas possible est-ce
que vous encouragez l'installation d'une
ZAD sur place mais les gens qui veulent
installer une salle d'installeront une
date sans mon avis enfin je veux dire
ils attendent pas la vie de Sandrine
Rousseau pour le faire ou ne pas le
faire est-ce que vous aimeriez que je
fasse
désinstalle une Jade et bien j'irai sans
doute dormir là-bas parce que je pense
que le que l'eau est un bien
suffisamment précieux pour que nous
lutions pieds à pied sur place donc
c'est ce que vous souhaitez qui est
l'installation du Zen d'une ZAD et qui
je vous dis que je ne souhaite rien du
tout et que ça n'est pas moi qui ai rien
installé mais que vous irez dormir vous
êtes quand même dans une prochaine
radicale de l'écologie aujourd'hui en
raison de cette urgence j'imagine non
mais l'urgence et d'une ampleur que nous
refusons de regarder il y a eu le
dernier rapport du GIEC encore une fois
qui est sorti dans l'indifférence
générale nous devons diminuer de moitié
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
les insectes ont disparu de 70% là les
populations d'insectes se sont
effondrées effondrés et l'essentiel de
cette effondrement est liée à l'usage
excessif de pesticides dans
l'agriculture quand est-ce qu'on réagit
quand est-ce qu'on réagit on met nos
enfants en danger mais dans un danger
vital là comment on fait pour alerter
sur les dangers auquel on expose la
population comment on fait pour modifier
notre système quand est-ce qu'on fait en
sorte que tout argent public aille à
l'adaptation et à la transformation de
notre système social et écologique en
vue d'une résilience là on fait comme si
et d'ailleurs Macron est l'emblème de
cela on fait comme si on a les continuer
dans un système productiviste de PIB de
PIB et que il y a une espèce
d'innovation technologique qui va nous
tomber du ciel à un moment donné qui va
nous sauver ça n'est pas vrai ça n'est
pas vrai nous avons une responsabilité
historique et même j'ai envie de dire
tellement historique que il y a peu de
générations qui ont eu une telle
responsabilité en réalité saurons-nous à
la hauteur de l'enjeu serons-nous
suffisamment intelligents collectivement
pour comprendre notre responsabilité et
bien aujourd'hui forcer de constater que
le système en place se défend violemment
et bien nous serons nombreux et
nombreuses à nous défendre pacifiquement
pour faire en sorte qu'il change on va
parler du contexte social et de la
réforme des retraites et des suites de
la réforme des retraites Elisabeth
borgne hier soir dans un entretien
l'Agence France presse annonce qu'elle
n'aura plus recours au 49-3 en dehors
des textes budgétaires ça vous satisfait
mais enfin
c'est dramatique c'est dramatique c'est
à dire que voilà maintenant ils vont
nous faire le changement de méthode je
pense que ça fait à peu près la septième
fois qui nous font le changement de
méthode je pense qu'ils vont nous faire
le coup de la pédagogie qui n'ont pas
suffisamment bien fait etc je pense que
ça fait 20 fois qu'il nous faut le coup
de la pédagogie et maintenant la phrase
qui m'a le plus
scotché je dois dire ce weekend c'est la
question de on va faire des textes plus
courts comme s'ils les parlementaires
n'arrivaient pas à comprendre un texte
plus long non mais vraiment faut qu'ils
arrêtent il faut qu'ils arrêtent cet
état d'esprit qui consiste à dire qu'ils
ont raison contre tout le monde ils
n'ont pas raison contre eux sur le 49 3
non mais elle va arrêter le 49-3 sauf
sur les textes budgétaires à tel dit bon
bah donc elle n'arrête pas les 49,3
qu'ils arrêtent de nous prétendre pour
des imbéciles vous demandez la
suppression du 49-3 mais bien sûr que je
demande la suppression du 49-3 c'est
jérémyordanov qui a fait un texte
là-dessus et il a bien raison parce que
le 49-3 est un déni de démocratie
Elisabeth borne avait également
l'apaisement avec les syndicats c'est ce
qu'elle dit toujours dans cet entretien
elle va recevoir les groupes
d'opposition la semaine prochaine que
lui demandez-vous mais il est temps il
est temps qu'elle les reçoivent
normalement dans un conflit qui dure
depuis autant de semaines elle aurait dû
être accroché à son téléphone pour
essayer d'avoir les formations
syndicales dans son ministère au moins
une deux trois cinq dix fois pendant ce
conflit elle n'a jamais décroché son
téléphone donc oui elle va recevoir les
groupes d'opposition et puis elle va
faire de la pédagogie et puis elle va
leur dire qu'elle va changer de méthode
et puis tout voir commencer comme avant
enfin vraiment c'est ce sont des
hamsters qui il faut y aller il faut que
vous dites ça sert à rien d'aller assez
d'entretien bien sûr Cyrielle châtelain
et puis qu'elle écoute et elle va
écouter le hamster qui tourne dans ça et
voilà et puis on va recommencer comme
avant est-ce que ce qui se passe là ne
nous dit pas aussi quelque chose sur
cette difficulté vous rend la
possibilité à réformer la France
mais il y a une possibilité de réformer
la France d'ailleurs elle se réforme
très régulièrement mais pas par la
méthode autoritaire et violente qu'ils
ont choisi là je rappelle quand même
parce que c'est pour moi c'est le
chiffre qui dit tout entre les 5% des
salariés les plus pauvres et les 5 % des
salariés les plus riches il y a 13 ans
d'espérance de vie de différence très en
et on dit tout le monde part à 64 ans
on mesure l'injustice on mesure la
violence sociale que ça représente donc
en fait la France refuse de dégrader son
système social les Français et
Françaises refusent que l'on dégrade
leur système social et bien ils ont bien
raison ils ont bien raison et en fait le
peuple français est aujourd'hui le
premier garant du système social en
réalité demain dans ce contexte de
fortes tensions sociales et de violence
aura lieu une dixième journée de
mobilisation contrairement aux huit
précédentes la devienne la neuvième
jeudi dernier a été maillée de violence
en marge en des cortèges syndicaux
est-ce que vous êtes inquiète pour la
journée de demain est-ce qu'il ne serait
pas plus prudent qu'elle n'est pas lieu
alors c'est exactement ce que cherche le
pouvoir ça qui est que la violence se
dissuade les manifestations donc non
nous serons présents je serai présente
et nous serons présents en masse demain
dans les rues parce que il s'agit de nos
vies et que il n'y a aucune mais pas
plus en France que par tout dans le
monde la violence des répressions
n'est un aucune révolution quel est
votre quel est votre ordre pour demain
allons-y allons-y pacifiquement allons-y
avec de beaux slogans et prenons la rue
comme nous l'avons toujours pris
c'est-à-dire de manière quand même très
déterminée mais très joyeuse aussi moi
c'est ça qui me fascine dans ces
manifestations c'est que je n'ai jamais
vu de manifestations aussi joyeuse et
aussi
solidaire en fait il y a vraiment
quelque chose de l'ordre de d'une
volonté farouche de changer ce système
et c'est je pense même que ça dépasse un
peu la retraite Darmanin ces derniers
jours dénonce cette violence inexcusable
pour reprendre son terme de l'ultra
gauche a-t-il
et secondo est-ce qu'elle nuit au
mouvement cette violence et bien
j'aimerais le Darmanin dénonce avec la
même passion la violence de ces forces
de l'ordre plutôt que de dire que c'est
de la fatigue d'individus isolés
j'aimerais beaucoup que Gérald Darmanin
donne des consignes d'apaisement des des
du maintien de l'ordre des forces de
l'ordre j'aimerais beaucoup que Gérald
Darmanin sortent l'IGPN de la police
pour qu'il y ait une formation
indépendante qui soit en capacité de
juger les exactions des policiers qui
qui jettent l'eau propre sur l'ensemble
des forces de l'ordre oui j'aimerais que
Gérald darmaninettes qui sont ouvertes
pour vous ce ne sont pas des enquêtes
indépendantes si mais l'IGPN est à
l'intérieur de la police et ça fait
partie des sujets dans bien des pays
l'IGPN est sorti de la police et
d'ailleurs je salue la chef de l'IGPN
qui est a été la seule à ma connaissance
à avoir eu des mots forts sur ce qu'on
l'enregistrement qui est sorti des
braves m et qui a dit que sa jetait
l'eau propre sur l'ensemble de la police
c'est la seule c'est la seule
aujourd'hui
faites confiance sur ces enquêtes oui je
lui fais confiance sauf que je serai
encore plus en confiance il l'IGPN était
sorti de la police et que la police des
polices ne soit pas dans la police c'est
quand même la base en fait et ça ne
résoudrait pas tous les problèmes mais
ça permettrait de Ré un petit peu de
confiance chaque année contre des
policiers en France oui mais là en
l'occurrence on voit bien que
ce qui s'est passé parce qu'en fait il y
a à la fois les sanctions de ceux qui
sortent de du droit commun mais il y a
aussi une politique du maintien de
l'ordre qui ne va pas et en l'occurrence
sur les bassines par exemple
on ne sait pas si les policiers ont été
en dehors du droit commun c'est on
dépassé la ligne rouge de ce qui est
interdit ce qui a posé problème au
bassine c'est les consignes c'est les
ordres de maintien de l'ordre c'est ça à
poser problème et donc nous avons une
politique de maintien de l'ordre en
France qui est bien trop brutal on l'a
vu avec les gilets jaunes on le voit
avec on le voit avec les bassines et je
le dis aux forces de police je le dis au
ministre de l'Intérieur la police n'est
pas là pour garantir votre politique
elle est là pour garantir la paix
sociale c'est ça normalement le l'objet
et l'objectif de la police et pour vous
géraldarin partage pas ça et là non
Gérald Darmanin utilise la police à des
fins de maintenir ses réformes à lui les
réformes de son gouvernement cela n'est
pas possible la dissolution de la brave
m n'est pas l'ordre du jour c'est ce que
dit le préfet de police de Paris vous
l'a demandé toujours non seulement elle
n'est pas à l'ordre du jour mais en plus
il est prévu qu'elle augmente puisque
aujourd'hui il y a 92 équipages de la
bravène et pour les JO les Jeux
Olympiques à Paris il est prévu que ça
monte à 150 donc non seulement il n'est
pas question au sein du gouvernement que
cette brigade se disparaisse mais en
plus elle est appelée à augmenter nous
demandons sa dissolution nous demand
tendance à dissolution ne serait-ce que
par l'intimidation qu'elle génère dans
les manifestations il n'est pas possible
que des gens arrivent en scooter que des
policiers arrivent en scooter en moto ou
en quad avec l'effet que ça d'arriver en
bande comme ça et avec des matraques
étape à tout va cela n'est pas possible
en démocratie et donc oui il nous faut
une dissolution de cette bravème qui est
une honte à notre démocratie Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a eu une phrase qui fait
réagir et il a dit que si la nuque
arrive un jour au pouvoir il faudra
soigner les policiers de la brave les
membres la brave vous partagez ça
je pense que
soigner il a voulu dire que il n'était
pas normal qu'il que des policiers
ce satisface d'utiliser la violence
comme cela et bien là-dessus oui il
n'est pas normal que des policiers qui
ont quand même un mission de service
public se satisface vous dites aussi
qu'il faudra les soigner non moi je dis
pas ça mais je dis qu'il n'est pas
normal que des policiers qui sont dans
mon charge d'une mission de service
public se satisface de cette violence
Olivier Véran le porte par le
gouvernement dans le Journal du Dimanche
dit qu'il y a un continuum entre la
violence du discours politique elle est
violence exprimée dans la rue quand
dites-vous
il est vraiment arrêté avec cela je lui
dis arrêter avec ces éléments de langage
ils ne mettent que de l'huile sur le feu
ils ne font que souffler sur les braises
à ton vraiment besoin de cela en ce
moment ce qui met la France à feu à 100
c'est votre violence sociale c'est la
violence sociale dont vous faites preuve
depuis le début du mandat je rappelle
que la réforme des retraites se
sédimente avec celle sur le chômage où
on diminue les allocations chômage on
oblige les gens à accepter n'importe
quel emploi en les privant d'argent
c'est ça c'est ça la violence sociale
dont vous faites preuve c'est le fait
d'annoncer
lors d'une allocution du Président de la
République à 13h la seule mesure qui est
annoncée et celle de 15 heures de 15 à
20h de travail pour le RSA pour les
dépositaires du RSA enfin vraiment c'est
ça la violence sociale dont vous faites
preuve c'est ça qui met le pays à feu à
100 parce que nous sommes un pays qui
aimons notre système social et à juste
titre il est unique au monde
est-ce que vous allez continuer à
assiéger au Parlement Fabien Roussel
pose la question de l'utilité pour les
parlementaires de continuer à ce sujet
dans cette dans ce climat et dans ces
conditions quel est votre position
je continuerai à siéger mais j'en ai
fait à chaque fois que je vais à
l'Assemblée nationale j'ai un sentiment
de malaise en ce moment ce que je me dis
à quoi sert cet instant s'il y a de
belles dorures sur les murs et au
plafond il y a du beau velours rouge
mais au fond c'est un théâtre de pouvoir
mais ça n'est pas le pouvoir n'est pas
là puisque on déni le pouvoir au
Parlement et je le dis parce que
ça peut être ça peut paraître très
lointain pour les citoyens et citoyennes
mais à partir du moment où le Parlement
devient une coquille vide juste un
décorum de pouvoir la démocratie est en
danger et la démocratie est quand même
le bien le plus précieux que nous avons
pour décider des politiques publiques
pour décider du partage des richesses
pour décider de tout ce qui fait notre
avenir enfin une forme de tristesse dans
vos propos pourtant 49-3 n'est pas
nouveau celui qui l'a le plus utilisé
c'est Michel Rocard de gauche alors déjà
il l'a pas utilisé sur un temps aussi
court que celui d'Elizabeth borne est
par ailleurs le 49-3 que ce soit utilisé
par Michel Rocard ou pas Elisabeth borne
et toujours
et toujours une erreur toujours une
erreur et toujours un aveu de faiblesse
toujours un aveu d'autoritarisme d'un
gouvernement qui ne sait pas trouver de
majorité on parlait de l'Assemblée à
l'instant et cette hypothétique
dissolution d'assemblée qui est toujours
une possibilité pour Emmanuel Macron
pour retrouver une majorité et en même
temps dernier sondage il faut pour le
JDD
donne une préférence rassemblement
national dans l'hypothèse d'une
dissolution ça vous inquiète
mais évidemment que ça m'inquiète mais
moi je veux une dissolution pour
précisément nous allions convaincre les
gens et que nous allions refaire
campagne et que nous formions un
parlement qui soit
issue de ce mouvement social en fait les
sondages ceux qui convaincent le
rassemblement national de la nuit oui
mais les sondages se sont trompés bien
des fois et par ailleurs le
rassemblement national et je le dis aux
électeurs et électrices n'est pas une
issue puisqu'ils n'ont jamais défendu
les petits jamais contrairement à ce
qu'ils ont ce qu'ils ont un discours
là-dessus mais
cette bataille ce combat de la rue de
leur favorable dans la perception dans
un sondage il y a une augmentation de du
rassemblement national moi je dis juste
aux électeurs électriques le
rassemblement national ne défend pas les
petits je le redis au moment de la loi
pouvoir d'achat il y avait la
possibilité de voter les amendements
d'augmentation du SMIC qui aurait été
aussi une forme de solution à la au
manque de financement des retraites et
bien ils s'y sont opposés ils n'ont pas
voté cette augmentation du Smic ils ont
essayé de se rattraper tant bien que mal
après avec une avec une proposition loi
qui était ni fait ni à faire et qui en
fait n'augmentait pas de manière
structurelle le SMIC mais voilà ils
n'ont pas voté ça ils ne l'ont pas fait
ils ne sont pas en soutien des petits
ils disent qu'ils le sont ils disent
qu'ils le sont mais c'est comme dans ce
compte vous savez où il y a le loup qui
tremble sa patte dans la farine et qui
montre sa patte blanche derrière la
vitre de la porte pour mieux manger les
agneaux et bah c'est cela en fait le
Front National et le rassemblement
national ils mettent leurs pattes dans
la farine pour montrer patte blanche
mais la réalité est qu'ils n'ont rien à
faire des petits un mot sur une
législative qui n'est pas un sondage
c'était la législative partielle hier
dans l'Ariège le second tour opposera
donc la candidate sortante la députée la
France insoumise à la candidate
dissidente socialiste et c'est un peu
une surprise elle progresse de 9 points
elle a éliminé le rassemblement comment
avez-vous regardé ces résultats déjà que
ces deux se sont deux candidates de
gauche qui sont au deuxième tour et que
ça fait du bien et après Bénédicte
taurine a quand même une avance
conséquente sur la challengeuse qui est
PS dissidente et que je la félicite de
ce score parce que elle arrive largement
en tête et vous voyez là on n'est pas
dans un sondage on est dans la réalité
dans votre et dans la réalité du vote et
bien
une terre de gauche oui mais la nuit
pêche a progressé et la nuit Pesse est
alors là elle recule un peu par rapport
au mois de juin largement c'est la
socialiste d'ici donc qui progresse
fortement non mais elle est largement
tête et la gauche est au deuxième tour
puisque ce sont deux candidates de
gauche donc vraiment voilà n'ayons pas
peur d'une dissolution est-ce que vous
appelez la candidat dissidente
socialiste à se retirer comme le fait la
direction du Parti socialiste vous
comprenez cet appel
oui je le comprends parce que la nuit
Pesse ça n'est pas une simple alliance
électorale c'est la construction d'une
alternance future à une politique
libérale et ça ne nécessite pas de coup
de canif dans cet accord en fait c'est
quelque chose qui va s'installer il y a
pas c'est pas une triangulaire donc ce
sera est-ce que c'est pas aux électeurs
de trancher entre la dissidente
socialiste et la candidate à la fille
mais il peut y avoir il peut y avoir des
des électeurs qui tranchent mais là
profondément nous avons une
responsabilité face à la montée du
rassemblement national c'est de proposer
une alternative et une alternative qui
s'inscrit dans le temps qui est ancré
qui est enraciné pas une alternative qui
est comme un bouchon à la surface des
mers et qui qui est comme ça ballotté
d'élection en élections nous devons
avoir une construction au long cours et
enraciner et c'est ça que fait la nups
donc oui j'appelle la dernière question
vous prenez l'exemple de l'Ariège pour
dire voyez
d'une dissolution parce que la gauche
peut gagner la nuit pèse peut gagner
mais est-ce que c'est pas un coup de
poker par rapport au ressemblement
national au niveau du pays moi je n'ai
pas de solutions devant les électeurs et
électrices je n'ai pas peur de cela je
sais qu'il est enfin je sais combien ils
sont attachés aux valeurs de solidarité
à un modèle social à une radicalité
écologique combien ils veulent que notre
société change je n'ai pas peur de cela
et j'ai envie vraiment mais mes
collègues à ne pas en avoir peur merci
Sandrine Rousseau merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin merci Fabrice
on passe au club des territoires